guten tag und willkommen zu heute
express in halle an der saale sind zwei
menschen auf offener straße erschossen
worden
der tatort in der nähe einer synagoge
wurde abgesperrt zunächst dieses zwei
täter seien mit einem auto auf der
flucht inzwischen wurde eine person
festgenommen entwarnung hat die polizei
aber noch nicht gegeben
die bundesanwaltschaft hat die
ermittlungen übernommen
schüsse auf offener straße mitten im
paulusviertel in halle nahe der synagoge
mit einer großkalibrigen waffe feiert
einer der täter kurz darauf ist die
polizei am tatort ein anwohner erlebt
die tat aus nächster nähe mit geschossen
und dann war da maschinen klingt das
mädchen das kostbare schreiben dann aber
die sind gar nichts ist ein totaler
kampfes wirst du mit helm schutzkleidung
also komplett bewaffnet stolzieren die
maschine war und dadurch werde das kommt
mir jetzt oder balladen rote
friedhofsmauer
sie haben auch grund explosionen gehört
genau kurz nach der tat gibt die polizei
halle bekannt dass zwei personen getötet
worden sind
die täter seien auf der flucht anwohner
sollen zu hause bleiben
auch im 15 kilometer entfernten
landsberg sollen schüsse gefallen sein
das hat die polizei allerdings nicht
bestätigt die täter sollen dort ein taxi
gekapert haben und weiter auf der flucht
sein wie viele es sind ist noch unklar
die fahndung läuft die polizei hat
inzwischen einen tatverdächtigen
festgenommen und die bundesanwaltschaft
die ermittlungen übernommen
kaufmann in magdeburg wie ist der
aktuelle stand der dinge was wir bisher
wissen ist dass zwei menschen auf der
straße im paulusviertel erschossen
wurden die polizei geht von mehreren
tätern aus
mindestens einer hat eine schwere
kampfausrüstung mit helm und
kugelsicherer weste getragen und derzeit
sind die mutmaßlichen täter auf der
flucht eine person konnte die polizei
bisher festnehmen weitere details oder
hintergründe zur tat gibt es aber im
moment noch nicht wie schätzt die
polizei die gefahr für die bevölkerung
an
die polizei peine gefahren also eine
warnung herausgegeben die leute sollen
sich in den wohnungen und an sicheren
orten aufhalten nach wie vor das
bahnhofsviertel paulus viertels alles
abgesperrt und auch eine gefahren
warnung ist rausgegangen für landsberg
das 15 kilometer ungefähr entfernt von
halle
dort sollen schüsse gefallen sein es ist
noch nicht bestätigt aber auch da gilt
die leute sollen in den wohnungen
bleiben und es gibt eine ruf ein
notruftelefon quasi unter der 115 der
können sich die bürger melden
vielen dank für diese informationen
jahre hoffmann in magdeburg so weit
heute express vielen dank für ihr
interesse und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]